here are some option quotes from
cnbc.com and my goal here is to really
just familiarize you with the quote so
you know what you're looking at so the
first thing to realize is that options
are categorized by expiration dates so
these options that I've listed right
here are expiring in April 2011 and
options expire they usually expire on
the third Friday of any month or I guess
it to be to be exact the third Friday of
the month is the last day that you could
trade them they officially expire the
Saturday after that and these are
options on GE the last stock quote it
last traded at $18.95 and the way that
it's listed on cnbc.com and it tends to
be listed this way pretty much anywhere
that you look at option quotes is that
they list the calls on one side and then
the puts on the other side and these are
obviously calls and puts on General
Electric and then they write the strike
prices down the middle in increasing
order so the first column this is just
the symbol for that particular option
this is the last trading price this is
how much it's changed that day the low
and the high give the range of trading
that day on that option volume tells us
how many options actually traded that
day and open interest which is something
that you're probably not familiar with
if you've only looked at stock quotes
tells us how many actual open options
contracts of that type are actually in
existence so if you look right over here
this tells us that there's 399 open
köppen call options with a 14 dollar
stock strike price and in April 2011 the
2011 expiration on General Electric it
tells us that none of those 399 open
options actually traded that day if any
of these 399 options get exercised then
I'll go down to 398 if someone writes a
new option then it'll go up to 400 and
the way it's listed here is that the end
the money options are listed in this
light blue color and then the out of the
money options don't get the light blue
color and so you can see the in the
money call options are the ones that
have the strike price below below
so today's current strike price because
if you had a call option for 17 dollars
that gives you the right to buy GE for
17 dollars and if you exercised it today
you'd buy it at 17 and you could
immediately sell that stock for 1895 so
you would immediately make a dollar 95
profit and you can see right here that
the stock is or the option I should say
is actually trading a little bit above
that and that's because it has the
option ality you can definitely make a
dollar 95 on it but you might want to
keep it around because you can
potentially get the upside on GE stock
up to the third Friday of April 2011
while having a limited downside the most
you could lose here is the price that
you paid for your option and then you
can see the put options that are in the
money are the ones that have a strike
price above the current trading price if
I had a $20 if I had a put option with a
$20 strike or $20 exercise price that
means that I could go out into the
market today buy the stock for $18.95
and then immediately sell it for $20 so
I would make an immediate dollar 5
profit and you can see here that the
option is trading for a little bit more
than a dollar 5 because of the
optionality